[Music]
ari emanuel is the guy who runs runs uh
wme which is what the show the who's the
show entourage they based the character
ari gold off of our emanuel so he's like
this hot shot agent or whatever i've
heard ari emmanuel in a couple articles
they say that's what he does he'll call
someone every single day until he gets
what he wants and i think that's a i've
been picking this up as a thing like
i'll give you an example of you you you
actually do this when we were like all
right we're going to make like our own
podcast studio it's like yeah cool idea
and everybody kind of nods and okay
what's one level better than that
somebody's like oh you know i'll take
charge of it i'll come up with a plan
and then that person usually goes around
asking what the budget should be like
you know they kind of push the ball
forward nudge it forward with their toe
and then somebody else is like okay i'm
going to get this done and i'm going to
get this done in two weeks which seems
like aggressive right you go from no
studio to a fully functioning podcast
studio
no i'm like let's go yeah you were like
okay what are you doing right now and i
was like i'm on the phone with you and
you're like cool what are you gonna do
like right after this you ready to go
i'll kick i'll pick you up
and i was like what uh i guess i could
find a babysitter for my child and like
i guess i could and so we and then all
of a sudden an hour later i'm in the car
with you we're driving to ikea
and you walk in and you're like hey um
ikea guy
we need like an awesome studio couch and
he's like okay
and you're like um here's 500 in cash
where do i spend this like to get the
couch and they were like what the
is going on it's a different level of
intensity and sure enough
by like the next day we had those two
red couches that were like you're like i
need a couch you got a vision you're
like i need a couch yeah that's gonna
pop in the thumbnail of a youtube video
and so like i want it to look like this
and then we had it and you're like cool
you know our accounting person is gonna
paint the room today and then like you
know this next person's gonna do this
and like all of a sudden like the world
just bent to your will
and i'll have another i'll give you
another example me and my buddy suli we
invest in this company
and i put 50k in he put slowly put like
100k in and so we were like all right
great um now a couple months go by and
we're like
dude these guys like are they what are
they doing and so we like check in with
them and like nine months later and
we're like hey what's the latest
and they were kind of like you know
doing their thing but they they weren't
they didn't have like a clear plan and
they wanted to raise money
so they were like asking us for intros
and we were like cool send us your deck
and they sent us the deck it sucked and
we were like hey guys this deck kind of
sucks like i don't want to make intros
like let's work on your deck and they're
like oh thank you we'd love some help so
we get on a call
and we get on a call before we get on
the call okay that was like
they're like let's do a call your what
times are free for you next week silly
goes
i'm free in like 45 minutes can you get
to can you get to a computer by then and
they're like uh yeah
in the 45 minutes between then he sent
three emails with like slide one this
sucks slide three what is this picture
this is stupid side five present it this
way slide nine and he just had it but
like before the meeting he'd done the
meeting then we get into the meeting and
he's like all right guys i sent you guys
a bunch of stuff uh like let's open up
powerpoint right now and just fix it and
they were fixing it and he's like okay
cool um there's like these three things
that are missing
um like all right let's do a call like
in four hours
with the deck fixed with those three
things that we're missing
and um let's do this call every morning
and every afternoon we're gonna do two
calls a day for the next five days or
until this deck is amazing
and these guys are just like what
and i was also like are they
what's the reason what's the result of
that well they've they've gone on to
raise money though honestly the result
of that was i think by day four they
were just sort of like i hate you like
we disagree or like you know this is
just too much for us they kind of like
backed off and we're just like because
by the end of that we were like not only
does your deck need to change your
business strategy needs to change
because like the deck can only just tell
a great business story but you don't
actually have a great business story so
we need to fix that too
and like you know and it was like we
were are kind of like you know the
delivery wasn't the softest so i don't
think they loved the calls at first it
was like wow this is really constructive
feedback and by the end i think they
were just beating down and like
like
was dan was dan porter a guy who took it
to a level 12. is that what you're
saying that how he pushed so he told me
the stories of ari doing it he told me a
story of richard branson doing it and
then he had stories of him doing it he
was like because we were asking about
the milk road he reads the milk road
every morning and so we were like all
right
you know what would you do about this
and this and this how did you do that
early days of his latest project so i
should introduce that so he
after the wme thing he's like he started
this new company called overtime which i
don't know if you've which has like
taken over the world but i don't even
entirely know what it is but like their
social handles are all over the place
they're huge on social so basically it's
like
if you're into bat i started with
basketball now they have like football
and other things but it started with
basketball and basically what they did
was
they just create like a media company
but instead of the way like okay espn is
a tv channel
and then like bleacher report and others
were websites and then there were some
newsletters and these guys were like no
we're just gonna be like an instagram
account and we're just gonna become the
biggest instagram account for basketball
culture
and uh what does that mean it's like
crazy dunks like high school prospects
that's really where they like found
their foothold was they were like okay
forget the nba like like
hoops culture they're really interested
like who are the next who's the next
lebron
and it turns out there was this kid zion
williamson who was this like tank
looking guy in south carolina that
people had heard of he's got a cool name
called zion the guys built like a
you know crunch bar right and
then he can fly like he's like you know
he's like a flying bus and so a crunch
yeah like a double crunch
i would have thought like thicker than a
snicker but all right we're gonna go i'm
not perfect okay
um so he
so they started so they were like okay
they put up a video of this guy and it
was like it immediately went viral he's
like okay cool people want to know about
zion espn they're not sending a reporter
down to like greenville south carolina
to like cover this guy's high school
game against west bishop baptist like
it's like but we can do that and so he
he basically and he said this thing when
he when i was talking to him he was a
very calm guy
but he had that that level 12 intensity
i could tell because he goes
he goes i decided i was going to do this
and then i just applied my will against
it and i was like only somebody who is
like knows they're a force of nature
would even say something like that he
wasn't pitching me he wasn't selling me
he was just i was trying to figure out
how the did you build this into
like a household name in such a short
period of time and i've seen so many
people how do they
and how do they make money do you know
uh they have a couple different ways so
i think they have like you know probably
like sponsors or whatever but they now
have their own basketball league
so he's like he basically created his
own version of like a
like a instead of the ncaas it's like
you can come play in the overtime league
so right now he's like living in atlanta
where they're doing the season
and like and i told him i was like dude
you look like a high school science
teacher
well yeah so if you if you guys look up
dan porter when i hung out with him he
was like dressed cool and he looked like
the cool guy but he looked more
he's more similar to malcolm gladwell
that he was a basketball fan
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's more of a
gladwell than an x that's for sure
like you would never think this is the
guy that's like
steering you know street culture and
hoops culture at the grassroots level
but he is he really is like maybe he
would have launched a poetry league over
a basketball league and i asked him i
was like
no actually i love football
and i was like what and he's like yeah
you know like and so he told me about
the approach that he took
of like he's like i was at wme
and um
he's like you know i
i we heard these stats which was
basically like
the foot the nfl was really worried
because they're like kids choose their
favorite team and league
at like um age 10 or 12.
um and then that's like who they're a
fan of for life it's like that's my team
i think that's my player and then like
they're fan of them for like decades and
he's like then we've asked like how do
you decide is it because of the city
you're from or whatever and they're like
no madden like whoever's the most fun to
play in madden or like whoever's colors
i like and he's like oh and the nfl
was also like oh and the local
sports owners were like oh because
if if every kid in philadelphia isn't
growing up an eagles fan if they just
like michael vick cause he's fast
in the game of bad and then like that's
a fan we just didn't get they're not
gonna buy tickets jerseys they're not
gonna like come to the games like this
is not gonna work the model will break
at that point and then also tv networks
were like yeah kids aren't watching tv
so um
like we gotta figure something else out
what are they doing they're playing
video games they're on social media
they're on instagram they're on
tick-tock and so his theory was like oh
okay so we need to build
the sports media brand on those networks
and then we just have to find the thing
that clicked and what clicked for them
was these like
young up and coming basketball players
um and then he like came up with the
craziest like they would basically
he's like all right we need um the clips
like we need those clips faster than
anybody else and so they came up with
crazy ideas like crazy ideas which was
like they would find
they would in their social media they
would be like hey who lives in like
south carolina
we need a photographer so like the
number one zion clip submitter to them
these clips that got millions and
millions of views basically built their
brand which is like a
multi-hundred million dollar brand now
was done by a guy who was like i think
like a plumber on like weekdays and he
would go to the games and like the
number two clip submitter was a student
at zion school who had broke his leg and
because he was in a wheelchair they put
him like courtside every game like
instead of going up in the bleachers so
he had like the best spot and so that
guy was submitting like these amazing
clips on his iphone and like that's what
was going viral right away and then he's
like espn or whatever would hit us up
and they'd be like hey um like can we
license your videos we'll pay you for
this license like it'll be like getty
images
and he was like me dude i don't
want to build getty and he's like how
about this hpn you can have it for free
you just have to tag us and put our
watermark on it and they're like idiot
done and so then they ended up promoting
the out of overtime like overtime
was everywhere because of that it was
like seen as incredible because it was
on espn all the time
[Music]
you